hi guys my name is Anna
I lead rapid innovation and prototype
and yet an elect which is advertising
technology company I know that I'm the
last doc for a day so I'm going to try
to keep it light short and entertaining
and informative infirmity in a way that
we're going to be solving important life
problems things like worry to go on
vacation or how to construct your
reading list important things because
we're all data people here we run a lot
of algorithms every day the question is
can we run an algorithm to help us solve
everyday problems and about one of the
such algorithms I'm going to talk today
this is George dancing in 1947 he
invents an algorithm called simplex it's
named top ten algorithms of the 20th
century and this algorithm is used to
solve linear problems linear problems
what the algorithm basically does it
goes around a feasible region
constrained by different linear
functions and it finds the first
intersection the optimal point between
your objective function and feasible
region linear problems are used widely
across industries they're used in
routing and logistics financial planning
how to allocate money across your
portfolio in manufacturing how to figure
out the perfect drilling on the chip and
in product mix and linear programs have
been available in Excel for quite some
time in fact it's just an add-on on your
machine however if you're on a Mac like
me good luck using
solver on Excel if you have a problem
with more than 200 decision variables
Excel is not an option and if you want
to integrate it into production with
some interesting web application Excel
is in our way together this is PI data
so obviously we will be solving this
problem with Python so during the next
10-15 minutes I'm going to give you a
crash course into linear programming
we're going to look at the
implementation in Python and then we're
going to dive in into important examples
of picking destinations for you
vacation so to solve a linear problem
you need to have three ingredients you
need to have an objective function what
you want to achieve we want to maximize
profit we want to minimize time what do
we want to do we need to have decision
variables things that we will be
modifying in order to achieve our
objective and we live in the linear in
the real world so we have a lot of
constraints we never have enough time
enough money other things so to give you
a small example of how linear problem
was going to look like if we are to pick
up what we're going to eat for dinner
and we want to satisfy a minimum intake
of protein of four units per day we have
two choices steak of peanut butter and
we want to have the minimum cost of
dinner this is how it's going to look
like in linear program we'll have x1 for
peanut butter x2 for steak our objective
function of cost and constraints of
satisfying minimum protein intake this
is how we're going to solve for it
graphically if our y-axis is steak and x
axis is peanut butter these are all
possible options the moment you bring
constraints you limit your feasible
region then you start moving your
objective function and the first time
your linear objective function is going
to cross feasible region voila this is a
solution so our optimal dinner solution
is going to be two steaks and $6 to
translate this problem in Python you
need to have two components you need to
have a solver and you need to have a
modeling framework as I've mentioned
linear programs is a very well
researched area in operation research so
you have a lot of solvers out there open
source and commercial solvers so we'd
highly discourage you from coding your
own solver a different thing is the
modeling framework this is where you
will bring all of your equations
together there are three main packages
that people use around
stipe I buy almond pulp by Omo doesn't
allow you to write your linear problem
in Python it requires you to write it in
a mathematical language and then it
compiles it for you so if you want to do
a very pythonic implementation with a
lot
dynamic variables it's not a good option
SAP I will require you to translate all
of your data into numpy arrays so if you
want to have very complicated mattresses
it's also not a great solution
my personal choice is pulp it had it's
open source it has very good licensing
very easy installation but most
important feature its interoperability
that means that you can very easily
switch from one solver to another if you
acquire a very expensive solver moving
forward you can very easily change it so
that's how the problem is going to look
in Pulp first we are going to define a
pulp object which is LP problem we are
going to append to it our decision
variables and then our objective and
constraints to solve the problem it's
just going to be one line Rob that solve
and the solution is going to appear like
this so enough of theory let's look how
solver actually how linear problems
actually solved if you want to follow
along I put two ipython notebooks on
github so weird you go on vacation there
are so many options out there you have
so many deal websites but the problem is
that we want to keep our costs down we
also have a limited number of days that
we can go on vacation so for this
example I scraped a data set from a
website which is called the climb com
they offer you multiple packages from
mountain biking in Peru to climbing
Basecamp of Everest the data set looks
like this we're going to have
destinations duration of the trip the
cost of the trip and a short description
of what our vacation is going to be if
we are plotting the data side the
packages vary from somewhere from two
days to up to two weeks and the cost
will be from $200 to $3500 coding this
problem in pulp we're going to first
create our LP problem we're going to
specify if it's a minimization problem
or a maximization error case we
keeping budget down and the data set is
loaded as a panda's data frame so we're
going to look through the data set and
for every row we are going to create a
decision variable and append it into
decision variable array our objective
function will be multiplying every
decision variable by the cost of the
trip and that's what we will be
minimizing and then constraints whatever
we pick we want to have all of our
decisions to be equal to ten days and we
can go overboard if you have more than
10 to 20 decision variables your
objective functions and your constraints
become extremely big so bob has this
very nice function of exploiting your
problem into a file with that LP
extension where you can get a very good
overview of how your function is going
to look like so this is our problem
defined every decision variable x cost
subjects to constrain what every we
pecks should be equal to 10 and a list
of our decision variables we do prop
that solve and assert that we reached
the optimal decision making and we want
to print out what the final cost is so
our vacation for 10 days is going to
cost us only $762 which is really not
bad and then no matter which modeling
framework you're using they're going to
give you this very cumbersome list and
you have to scroll and figure out ok
what my decisions 24 was so I just wrote
a small parser that is going to loop
again three decision variables and put
it very neatly into a data frame so the
final decision where we're going on
vacation we're going to go to Oregon for
about six days and to Maine under $762
for 10 days I think it's really not bad
another problem that I want to show you
is how to pick reading lists and it
sorry yeah
vacations that together it's cackling
yes that's a problem and you can do a
lot of variations on it in case if you
have some destination in mind for
example but you want to keep the cost
down you can put it as an ax constraint
so the good part about cleaning a
problem is it's really up to you and up
to your creativity as long as you follow
the rules and construct equations it can
be a different problem every time
exactly if you want main on destinations
for sure and but just keep my cost down
it can be one of your constraints for
reading list problem we I don't know
about you guys but every year promise to
myself that I'm going to read more so
with my friends we coded a problem where
we maximize for the number of books the
problem is that we all have limited
amount of days that we can dedicate to
reading books our reading speed is a
constraint and and to go through this
problem I scraped Goodreads that
provides a list of New York Times
bestsellers it gives you a very neat
data set where you get the author of the
book the name and the number of pages
again it's a panda's data frame if we
are going to plot it most of the books
on average have about 300 pages and
ratings are pretty much the same for a
New York Times bestsellers in a similar
fashion we're going to first define and
an object we are going to specify that
it's an LP maximize problem again we're
going to look through the decision make
through every row and assign every book
as a decision variable I think I didn't
mention but pulp allows you to specify
the lower bound and upper bound and can
it gives you an option to transform your
linear problem into integer problem that
means that every decision variable is
going to be binary then we're going to
parse through the box and we want to
whenever a number of books that we want
to pick we want to achieve the maximum
number
and our constraint is that we only have
five hours per day to read and we can
read it most 60 pages per hour that at
least my speed if you have another one
feel free to modify and whatever we can
pick we can't really exceed this limit
so after we defines a problem we are
going to export it as an LP file it's
going to give us a neat overview of how
our linear problem looks like and after
running this and parsing it we're going
to get to a very nice data set where we
will get one for the books that get
scheduled so it gives us about 46 books
which my opinion is a great gulf rise
next year
this is all the examples that I actually
have for you guys the promise to keep it
short I know that linear problems is
probably not as sexy as deep learning
but the most interesting part is that
most simple algorithms sometimes the
most efficient ones we use at my company
linear problems to optimize across
brands media assets it has more than
billion rows and linear problems work
magic for us thank you do you guys have
any questions or can we go inside
drinking hi yes it's actually involved
it runs under zero point 17 seconds for
about fourteen million rows of media
across 30 brands so you get about a
matrix with 30 brands and 14 million
media assets for them and 0.17 seconds
done
ah we are we're using GU LP as the sole
reasons we used and its death so it's
fully populated it really depends I
think your performance is going to
depend on how many constraints you have
if you have a feasible region big enough
it figures it out pretty fast if you
have a lot of constraints if you're
saying okay those brands cannot play
with this or if we're looking at the
destinations if you will give it a lot
of constraints and it starts it takes
more time to think about it so funny the
chest I talked about this in Portland
and after this a couple of people coded
with linear programming brewery visits
in Portland so I was a judge a selling
traveling salesman problem where they
took into account the distance and the
times that it takes and if you have two
days visiting Portland how many
breweries can you actually visit which
are close enough a lot of people use it
on fine examples I think once you start
bringing the distance into it and
closing opening times you can use it for
scheduling how many museums you want to
visit when you're traveling or covering
all of the landmarks grocery store lists
can be a very useful problem solve
between your programming it's that's
where you do that cert if you assert for
your solution it's just one line here
when you say did you achieve that
optimal result is just going to tell you
no no solution has been found yes
exactly it's going to speed it
admittedly if if there's a junior old
times that it takes to solve your
problems pretty fast it's going to tell
you immediately I have not found the
solution
we use this long like a staffing try to
see if we can staff customer service
using linear optimization we found that
there are so many constraints that it
would take 8 to 10 hours and just to run
so do you have any thoughts on just
generally the approach to how do you
speed up in linear optimization problem
did you guys use Python to do this or
you use Python Oh interesting
I think my first thing would be how can
you restructure a data set if I can
instead of putting into constraints if I
can redefine an objective function it
will be it will save so much more time
so instead of putting this in to
constrain try already pre calculate
things and just feed it a different data
set so if you can solve for constraints
beforehand I know this all is a
scheduling problem we used it for this
as well but I used Excel for that a long
time ago cool thanks guys have a great
day